hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my uh Shara day in video I'm
just I'm using Ned Stark as a stand-in
because there's there's no real good
media for ashara dayne she hasn't
appeared on the TV show there's no real
pictures of her in the books and there's
not they're not even that many pictures
from house day in anyway that's okay
though we still have a couple more
seasons we know we could see someone on
the show in a flashback maybe I've
already done an Arthur Dayne video and I
talked a little bit about the history of
how stayin in general in that so I'm not
gonna repeat that this is mostly going
to be about a char Danes a later life
most people when they talk about ashara
dayne talk about how she's kind of
looped in with the mystery behind Jon
Snow's parentage because a lot of people
think that in the wake of the Tower of
joy incident Ned Stark took Don Howe
stains ancestral blade back to their
home of Starfall where a shara Dane was
gave it to her and then he walked away
with baby Jon Snow in tow a lot of
characters inside the narrative in the
books as well as on the show think that
she is Jon Snow's mother just because of
all those coincidences including Catelyn
Stark she suspects that ashara dayne is
is the person that Ned was unfaithful
with I just rewind a little bit just add
some context to who she is she doesn't
sound like much of a character when
she's only mentioned in rumors but she's
very beautiful
supposedly coveted by a lot of people
including Eddard Stark but also his
brother Brandon Stark the only real
encounters that George are Martin has
written about her are relative to the
tourney at Harrenhal the really infamous
tournament with the knight of the
Laughing tree as well as Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna Starks encounter
but it was a huge tournament most of the
kingdom was there so a lot of other
stuff was going on too in the books
Barristan Selmy talks about her in
retrospect he was one of the people that
was infatuated with her so at the
tourney of Harrenhal he had hoped to win
the tournament in honor her obviously
didn't go down that way Rhaegar
Targaryen ended up winning and honored
Lyanna stark with the crown of blue
roses but bitter Barristan Selmy say
that five times fast believes that at
the tourney of Harrenhal someone
dishonoured her he doesn't know exactly
who it is but he believes that as a
result of that she had a stillborn child
and it led to her committing suicide by
jumping off the battlements at Starfall
and yet you have to remember that
Starfall is in the mountains of eastern
Dorne
so it'd almost be like someone jumping
through the moon door in the Vale now
that's really sad already and she didn't
commit suicide till after Ned Stark came
back to star fault but I would say you
know
pulled with the idea that her brother
had died he carried on their ancestral
blades so when Ned brought it back it
was proof that he was dead so that
probably just compounded any potential
grief if she really did have a stillborn
child that there's no actual evidence
for a stillborn child so we just had to
include it in the rumors Barristan Selmy
is a very honorable person so he's not
going to openly lie about something but
if he's really bitter about something
that happened a long time ago in the
past his memory of events might not be a
hundred percent now the best fan theory
I've seen that relates to Sharda
internee of Harrenhal being dishonored
is Brandon Stark because he also took
the Maidenhead of Lady Dustin this is
where things get a little relationshipy
because if you remember originally
Brandon Stark was betrothed to Catelyn
she only married Ned after Brandon was
killed by the Mad King along with their
father but if you remember Catelyn
sister being really crazy about the love
triangle that the three of them had with
Littlefinger it's kind of the same deal
with Lady Dustin and Brandon Stark she
just claims that Brandon never wanted to
marry Catelyn and while I don't think
that Brandon Stark is quite the
man-whore that Robert Baratheon is I
think if he was willing to take lady
Dustin's Maidenhead then he would
probably be willing to have sex with
other women too before they got married
Brandon is just said to be one of the
many highborn people that was infatuated
with ashara dayne
so think about it this way mushara Dayne
has a stillborn child in proximity to
when Jon Snow is actually born Ned Stark
maybe finds him at the Tower of joy
bored to his sister Lyanna stark and
rhaegar targaryen and sees a really easy
way to protect everyone's honor and hide
Jon Snow's true lineage so that nobody
wants to kill him so that like Robert
Baratheon doesn't want to smash his face
in
now even if that's true like even if
he's protecting his brother's honor as
well as Shara Dayan's honor and his
sister's honor and Jon Snow's life
things still and very very badly for
Shara Dane she still jumps off the
battlements although there is a fan
theory that she potentially went to the
east and took a new persona I always
have to admire people's theories about
certain characters secretly being other
characters there is a theory that ashara
dayne
secretly took the persona of Quaid and
went to the east with dawn and that dawn
is Lightbringer or I should say the true
version of Lightbringer because you know
technically in season two and Melisandre
sets Stannis his sword on fire and
starts burning they call that light
bringer if you choose to take
things in a literal way then yeah some
of the properties of dawn do sound a lot
like Lightbringer like the dole glow
that it gives off the fact that it was
made from a comet that crashed on planet
toast for it from a meteor I mean it's
the meteor blade if you want to make
some final fantasy jokes but there
really isn't a lot of evidence to back
that up and nothing I've seen on the
show so far supports either those
theories so hopefully that gives you
guys some more context for Ash our day
now we don't know if we're ever gonna
see her on the TV show but if they're
gonna do a tower of joy flashback then
they might also do some Starfall and she
was there at that time whenever ned
stark brought dawn back there having
many castings to confirm that so the
show could totally cut her out but let
me know in the comments do you think
that ashara dayne had a stillborn child
with brandon stark with Ned's older
brother if he was the kind of person
that slept around and they were all in
proximity at the tourney of Harrenhal
and super drunk just think about the
honorable person that Ned Stark is and
what he might have done in that
situation to protect everyone involved
you know Jon Snow char Dane and his
brother Brandon Stark in what Barristan
Selmy remembers about it even if his
memory might be a little bit twisted
he's an honorable person too so I think
it's more realistic to believe that Ned
Stark had absolutely nothing to do
sexually with ashara dayne
even though she was a proven hottie if
you're one of those fans that really
likes to write fanfiction there is a lot
of a Chardonnay in fan fiction out there
I generally I try to avoid that kind of
stuff but if you really enjoy it then
it's definitely out there for you to
find hopefully Martin will write some
more into the Canon about her you know
either wins a winner or a dream of
spring and just for reference a lot of
people like the most popular belief
right now is that wins a winner will be
done in spring of 2016 but speaking of
books we actually have a new giveaway
winner 10-ounce congratulations to
Christopher roll you win a copy of a
night of the seven kingdoms kindle
paperback whatever you want just be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I get your contact info
there's supposed to be a new Star Wars
The Force awakens trailer on Monday in
case that ends up dropping my Q&A video
for this will just end up posting later
in the week it's always a bummer to have
to bump videos but I feel like when it's
a Star Wars trailer that you're getting
bumped for you can't be too mad about
that but while you guys wait for my next
video you can click here to learn all
about arthur danes history in the books
and you can click here to catch up with
Walking Dead before tonight thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys in a couple hours
you
[Music]